do you care about politics
or maybe i should rather ask do you care
about politics in your favorite show or
series
regardless whether you answer this
question with yes or no
you may not be aware of how big a deal
thoughtful political writing can be in
storytelling
because the truth is deep down we all do
care how things are being run in the
world
our heroes live in and also by whom
this is especially obvious for stories
where the political system is unfair
or straight out evil and political
structures can give a story world
a level of color and realism that makes
it incredibly easy to engage with
but when i talk about politics i in no
way mean focusing purely on political
maneuvering
after all most of us don't want every
story to be a house of cards
much rather good political writing
usually is subtle
and only throws us small bits and pieces
of the overarching structure of the
society our heroes live in
while modern television has discovered
the value of political intrigue and
action
shonen manga might not exactly be the
first genre that comes to your mind in
this context
and yet one of the reasons one piece has
managed to become as
popular as it is today is the political
aspect oda has increasingly integrated
into the story
in fact one character in particular has
enriched one piece in a number of ways
that might not be obvious at first
glance because
vivi is a wonderful example of political
writing
done right with her introduction to the
story
oda also introduces a proper political
system for the first time
that made the overall story more
entertaining and successfully
distinguished it from other shonen
mangas competing with it over the years
bivy's character arc shows her growing
into a great political leader
and gives us an idea of oda's own
political values
not only does vv trigger important
character and story development
by teaching luffy to become a better
leader himself but she also enhances our
perception of the straw hat crew in
general
by clearly contrasting what makes them
so unique in the one piece universe
and i think that this power of political
writing especially in the subgenre of
shonen manga
is worth taking a closer look at because
betting their adventure in a sense of
realism allows our heroes to break out
of these everyday conventions we're
familiar with
and thus in turn help us escape from our
everyday lives
what makes vivi so different from any
other character that we've met in the
story up to this point
is that her character arc is not the
story of a pirate
but the story of a leader after the
introductory arcs of the east blue
meeting vivi is the beginning of the
first real saga
in the straw heads adventure spanning
over multiple different arcs
getting to know the princess of alabasta
and witnessing her struggle to
free her country from the grasp of one
of the seven warlords of the sea
introduces a conflict on a much larger
scale
than anything we've gotten up to this
point being a compassionate and brave
young woman
that cares deeply for her people it
quickly becomes clear that her task is
not to get physically stronger in order
to take down her political opponent
crocodile
but rather to become a better politician
herself
to do so right from the get-go oda
already equipped her character with a
number of traits that show us her true
potential
as a leader very very early on in the
story even as a kid
vivi already shows a notch for politics
and diplomacy
when slapped by an angry whipple she
keeps her cool
not to cause a major international
incident for her father and country
she also befriends a group of common
kids including the young coza
who later would lead the rebellion in
the civil war staged by crocodile
and in general far from being
authoritative and tempered
vivi fulfills the trope of the kind and
adventurous princess
that is brave and determined to take
action for her country's sake
thus she doesn't hesitate to infiltrate
crocodile's baroque work agency
at the age of only 14 and works her way
up the ladder
over a two-year period in which she even
learns how to fight
further she's also clearly able to deal
with pain
be it physical from being shot in the
shoulder or
psychological from losing egoron so when
she meets luffy
who very quickly comes to acknowledge
her determination she already shows
enormous promise to become a great
leader in the future
however crocodile manipulating her
country into a famine
and ultimately civil war proves to be
too much for her to handle
and she suffers deeply under her
people's hardship
falsely believing that she has to carry
her country's burden all on her own
it takes a quite emotional brawl with
luffy to show her that she needs to
start believing in her friends
and let them share in on her load still
in spite of luffy's speech she once
again tries to end the bloody battle
between the royal army and the rebels
all by herself
and not only does she fail to be hurt
she also fails to stop the bomb
planted by crocodile in the middle of
the city this
is the low point of a character arc
however
luffy defeating crocodile and finally
returning the reign
as well as pel sacrificing himself by
carrying the bomb away from the city
finally held vivi in overcoming her
biggest weakness as a leader
thus in her coming of age speech we
finally see a future queen
that has grown significantly through her
shared adventures with the straw hats
in contrast to the power focused pirate
battles we have seen up to this point
vivi introduces a political level to the
story
that up to this day helps distinguishing
it from other shonen
alabaster and the baroque work saga are
the first
real taste of political intrigue and
conflict in one piece
way before arcs like anna's lobby or
dressrosa that are even more centered
around political themes
with crocodile for the first time ever
we encounter an antagonist that
cannot simply be beaten by pure strength
alone
but rather has to be approached in
multiple steps over multiple arcs
requiring the skills of the entire crew
this brings an entirely new level of
complexity and tension into the story
that not only make the story less
predictable but also requires
more thoughtful and creative action from
our heroes
similarly the political level of
alabasta also enlarges the entire story
world we had known up to this point
for the first time it becomes clear that
the one piece world does
not only consist of small islands with
quiet villages
as we've exclusively seen in the east
blue much rather we learned that many
islands consist of entire kingdoms
with their own political systems that
have existed for hundreds
if not thousands of years this insight
broadens our view of the world
immensely and prepares us for the
overarching conflict with the world
government
thus vivi's character enables important
story development overall
i think it goes even further than this
because she also triggers important
character development for the entire
crew
and especially so for luffy see while
luffy teaches vivi about the importance
of trusting in your friends
and sharing the burden vv in turn
teaches luffy a crucial lesson about
leadership
after leaving little garden vivi
convinces the crew to make a detour for
the severely ill nami and find a doctor
on drum island
and upon arriving at the small village
on the island shore
the villagers led by the future king
dalton surround the ship and back in the
crew to turn around
over the course of this tense situation
vivi is
shot in the shoulder and seeing his
friend being hurt
luffy as he always does starts charging
at the villagers
however vivi stops him in the last
moment and goes down to the villages in
apology
she calls out luffy for his rash
reaction that might have caused nami's
life
and in this moment luffy makes a
graspable leap in his character
development
he bows down himself and asks for help
to save his navigator
the important lesson that vivi taught
luffy here
is that some situations cannot simply be
resolved through fighting alone
some situations call for diplomacy
strategy
or even humility this ultimately helps
luffy to become a better leader himself
and we can actually see his growth from
the scene in later arcs
on sabahodi for instance luffy actually
orders his crew to flee
realizing that fighting against an
admiral is futile at this point
and on jaya he and zoro do not fight
back against bellamy's men
just like shanks did not fight back
against the bandits back when luffy was
a kid
thus luffy has gotten a step closer to
shanks ideal of a great pirate
all through learning from vivi's words
and aside from her personal influence on
luffy and the others
her character benefits us the readers
even more
vivi is a character that is caught in
the gruesome normality of the one piece
world
no matter how hard she tries to take
things into her own hands and
change them with all her might she
doesn't seem able to escape the grasps
of the powerful forces at work in her
country
and while it's easy to confuse her
normality helplessness and frustration
as something of little importance when
looking at it through the lens of
typical shonen stories
what vivi's character actually does for
us is contrasting
how unique and special luffy and his
crew are in this unforgiving system
how they're actually physically and
mentally strong enough to take on these
major forces at work in the one piece
world
this is the true secret of the success
vivi has brought to oda's story
she allows us to widen our focus and
shows us that luffy
zara and ko are indeed not normal
this makes their adventure just the more
exciting as we now know just
how unique they actually are inside this
complex political web
of powerful and influential people being
able to carry out this fundamental
change in his approach to storytelling
in such a seamless way is part of the
genius of oda's writing
subtly integrating such conceptual
layers beneath the main plotline
and thus being able to share a richer
and more vivid world with us readers
is what i found truly thrilling about
one piece as a piece of literature
after all writing a character like vv
takes not only a lot of creativity and
skill
but also a significant portion of
bravery in a genre that otherwise has
been heavily dominated by ever repeating
power struggles
however far from making one piece less
exciting or intense
political characters like vivi actually
enhance and
contrast the protagonists and help bring
out the best in them
so in the end you may think that you
don't care about politics in your
favorite story
until you find out that you actually do
maybe
just not quite in the way that you
expect it to
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching what are your thoughts on vv
and her role in the story
and what character would you like to see
me discuss next
share your thoughts with me in the
comments below if you enjoy one piece
and want to learn more about
storytelling
world building or my thoughts on the
latest one piece chapter make sure to
like and subscribe to become part of the
channel right now
i hope to see you around next time and
until then
stay safe and have a wonderful week